bad policies have consequences did you
know Tom what city in America across the
board if you look at income
five to ten thousand dollar income range
then ten to twenty thousand dollar
cohort twenty to Thirty forty to fifty
fifty to sixty all the way down to you
know to 200 000 plus which city has the
most 200 000 plus earners In America
which city do you know because we talked
to yourself you're saying annual income
annual income which city has the most
200 000 earners I have two cities that
come to go for it you want to go first
no good uh well three cities that come
to mind I got New York I've got DC and
I've got San Francisco so it's DC okay
and by the way
and it's not even close okay now do you
know what is the number one sector in DC
that pays that kind of salary lobbyists
lobbyists in public administration these
are the types of jobs that they have
downtown by the way do you know what
city in America
is highest in crime today not even close
it's probably DC as well do you know
what city in America three for three
guys do you know what city in America is
the highest in homelessness per 1000
people I'm gonna take a wild guess and
say DC do you know what city in America
is that not is number one in larceny DC
do you know what city in America is
number one in uh burglary is it DC do
you know what city in number one is in
robbery I'll take DC for 200. do you
know do you know what city I can keep
going on and on and on and on in every
possible way DC is number one
and by the way here's the crazy stat
about DC do you know since 1975 when DC
became a district and they started
having Mayors do you know how many times
DC has had a Republican mayor since
1975. how many times do you think since
1975. since zero since 1975. that's 50
years how many times you think one never
never a single Democratic mayor ever
never not maybe once not twice they've
never had it so what does it tell you
terrible policies so people don't want
to move their companies over there they
just don't and by the way you know what
you know what community DC has been the
worst over the years black community
okay horrible if you go a little lower
on this article Rob go a little lower on
this article invite timmy.com go a
little Lord if you look at the if you
look at the numbers go lower lower lower
lower
look at that one right there 1985 the
anti-drug Abuse Act of 1986 they created
a law
that was hundred and two hundred to one
crack cocaine disparity which meant that
a person that got caught with crack
cocaine would receive a sentence that
was 100 times longer than a person I got
caught with the same amount of powder
cocaine who do you think they were
targeting African black and by the way
that's 1986 while the mayor is a
Democrat targeting blacks again bad
policies have consequences who in the
right mind is thinking about moving
their families to DC whom the right man
is thinking about moving their families
to San Francisco right now who the right
mind is saying you know what why don't
we move our business to San Francisco I
don't know a lot of people that are
thinking about that stuff the best part
that's going on right now the best part
that's going on right now man we finally
have a few years to look at policies to
say damn that didn't work when
you're in it and people are selling it
you may be like well maybe maybe it does
work let's wait and see if it works
guess what it didn't work San Francisco
failed miserably these see failed
miserably and continues to fill they
don't care about the community what's
going on over there anyways so I love
the fact that what we're looking at
these numbers in the flip side of it Rob
if you want to pull up the least
affordable City can I show you some
numbers about DC real quick
it let me go into this affordable I'll
come back to DC to to flip side of it
here's what happens when you have great
policies okay real estate is booming in
Miami why do you think it is hmm because
people are moving there yeah 900 a day
and it says it's not a good thing not if
you're making under 60 Grand a year and
need some sort of affordable housing
they're right however guess why and what
causes a city to increase pricing in
homes because those types of people are
shown up to your city with the average
income in mind residents would have to
sacrifice 80 of their monthly income to
own such a home la
comes in at a second number two with 77
percent of their income necessary to pay
for purchase home oddly enough Newark
New Jersey is third but that's most
likely due to New York City spillover
yeah it's a post pandemic New York City
itself is ironically ranked number four
seventy percent needed and then if you
go lower in 2021 62 percent more people
moving to Florida than moved out with
the state's population increasing by two
percent in a single year Miami's tax
rate uh uh with federal tax included are
about 10 lower than that of New York
City resident and a manhattanooi making
150 000 a year saves fifty thousand
dollars just to relocate to Miami okay
and by the way Orlando moved up seven
spots just so you know during the same
exact time what does this tell you bad
policies causes you to lose great people
great policies that the Santa sat in
Florida causes you to gain great people
very interesting concept and bad
policies attracts bad people and when
people say what do you mean by bad those
who are a net negative to society who
want reparation checks moved to San
Francisco those who say I don't need you
to give me any reparation checks just
leave me the hell alone let me build my
life let me raise my kids those people
are moving to places like Florida Texas
Tennessee it's great it's a case study
that's proven which policies attract and
produces results and which policies
attracts and produces trash by the way
Newsom is the case study that's losing
great people gaining net negative people
the same as the case study of gaining
great people losing net negative people
when Dwyane Wade said we can no longer
live yeah in Florida even though it's my
home and a lot of these people have my
jersey on the walls you believe
transgenders should be able to decide to
change their bodies seven eight years
old at eight nine years old yeah you
believe that yeah Florida yeah we we
don't think it's normal California does
move over there no problem do you mean
to tell me that's a net negative to
society
um in a way of confusing the hell out of
kids under the age of 18 yes that's an
that negative to society I say yes to
that so anyways you were going to say
some stats about DC uh well yeah just to
kind of give some Credence to you by the
way speaking of that crack epidemic uh
and going on in DC where does Hunter
Biden live these days
who was the only mayor in our country's
history to get arrested oh Marion Barry
Marion Barry the mayor of DC indicted
mayor Hall of Fame he's number one he's
on Mount Rushmore of indicted marriage
yeah he's his campaign thing I will get
the drugs off the street and into my
nose so it's like it was a great
campaign this was the uh uh Rob this is
the the stats on DC I'm sorry of the
highest end go to 20 20 census
okay yeah scroll down a little bit by
the way here are the counties where the
median household didn't come what you're
talking about look how many counties are
in Virginia now you know they call that
that area around DC the DMV DC Maryland
Virginia with all within you know a half
hour drive of DC let's count how many
are in Virginia DMV area Number One
Loudoun County Virginia number two Falls
Church Virginia then you get three and
four which is California no secret then
you've got Fairfax County we're all
familiar with in Virginia so that's
three out of the top ten then you got
Maryland Howard County Maryland then
you've got Arlington County Virginia
then you have California so
four in the top 10 are all in the
Virginia area so when we find out where
all this lobbyist money goes all these
slush funds go all this waste all this
pork belly they talk about right to
lining the pockets of the people that
work in DC
well and Amazon's uh second headquarters
is now I I I think it's one-third full
now and those are very high paying jobs
he helps and uh we can thank AOC for
that being in DC because she could have
been elsewhere so AOC you're so amazing
so great for helping those people but I
actually applaud you for pointing this
out because nobody talks about DC in
this regard we think of San Francisco's
expensive New York's expensive somehow
DC is not exactly in that conversation
but it definitely should hey if you
enjoyed this short hope you want to
watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called a vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be there I'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will gudera
the guy that ran 11 Madison in New York
if you run a business if you're a CEO
entrepreneur and executive this is not
an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August and September take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]